and joining us in the studio to talk
about promise if this and other
technologies in reducing animal testing
is the head of the department
responsible for alternative testing a
Germany's federal institute for risk
assessment professor gilbert should
feather thanks for joining us in the
studio now what do you think about the
idea of oregon chips is that may be the
breakthrough to get rid of all this
animal testing actually two very forward
looking promising innovation technology
which is under focus all over the world
right now actually what I wouldn't say
is that we get rid of all the animal
testings in the next two to five years
so that this technology brings us away
from more than seventy percent of all
and mystics right now mm-hmm but so you
think in principle it is possible to set
up a system which is very similar to a
human body right well if it will be very
similar to human body in the future and
I mix in the next two or ten years I
wouldn't say that we on that way already
we're very close to come to ideas that
we can bring different organs on a ship
together but however you know it took us
about 500 million years of evolution to
create an all organism like a human body
bringing all the organs together and
functional systems so it's very complex
and to build up such a system in such a
fast time to mimic the whole human body
and once I would say it takes a little
bit longer I understand so if we don't
look that far into the future I mean
what else is there can you work with
single cells or what other ideas are
there to reduce animal testing or there
is a whole bunch of ideas out we call it
the three options applets reduce meant
on its replacement and refinement so we
have tissues we have simple system we
have 3d systems like printers you know
printers which we know from just the
computer systems which prints a share on
the desk so we are following the
technology to print an organ by using
kind of 3d printers to rebuild a system
instead of just putting
everything just together I understand
and one day you might even be able to
simulate it in the computer oh we're
already simulating organ functions
that's what we call in silico
experiments but those experiments they
need a close combination of biological
experiments and the work together with
and bioinformatics or system biology but
we are trying to get all this data
together yeah but so i can tell that we
are heading towards the future which
could be very comfortable for animal
rights activists to want to ban all
animal testing just tell us what
happened if we did so what if we have to
go completely without animal testing I
would say if we would then animal
testings right now we get in huge
problems related to toxicity testing if
we don't have the right alternative we
would face side effects if we have drugs
which were not tested right now was
there anything in the past and
experience that tells us we need it
today well the whole story started with
quantum that was a drug which was taken
in the 60s by women which were pregnant
and at the end of turn out that their
babies had taratala gist teratology
effects so we don't definitely don't
want that again and similar effects
thanks a lot for the talk professor Xuan
fada